the whole Clinton operation I think was
very seamless and well run in the sense
that the people who were in it
it was a tight ship with the Biden
regime what what they were doing it
seems like a lot of these people it
wasn't so much ideological they were
just in it for the money and you can see
that on the hard drive you can see that
in the emails it was just we have a
chance to exploit the vice president's
son and I think that's why you've seen a
lot of these people sort of turn on the
Biden family now those that haven't been
dissuaded by stories like this and I
think that might be why they're actually
trying to come out so forcefully because
they know deep down the people like Eric
schwer and the Devon archers of the
world basically all of Hunter Biden's
you know Yale call or classmates and
peers and roommates they were just on
The Money Team right it wasn't like oh
we want to spread democracy abroad you
know we want to do whatever the uniparty
wants to do and all these no they just
wanted to turn a profit and those people
I think are very easily turned